alors on dirait que nous rejoignons
augustin legrand bonsoir vous êtes le
porte parole de l'association des
enfants de don quichotte vous sortez de
la réunion il ya quelques instants au
ministère de la cohésion sociale avec
jean louis borloo et catherine vautrin
ça s'est passé comment avec les
ministres donc laissés en cours je crois
que ça se passe bien je crois qu y eut
un tsunami médiatique les gens sont
sensibilisés maintenant il ya une forte
volonté d'agir médiatiquement aussi je
crois que c'est important que les gens
soient sensibilisés et monsieur borloo
veut utiliser sa pour évidemment agir
vite et bien
alors maintenant céder voilà on
travaille sur la charte je crois que
tous les points de la charte sont
acceptés c'est historique
a priori la charte du canal saint martin
va va ici dans les annales il va
révolutionner le paysage français au
niveau du logement
donc quand vous voyez la mobilisation du
gouvernement et des politiques de droite
comme de gauche autour des sans abri
vous estimez vous que vous avez déjà
gagné notre pari
non pas encore je crois que maintenant
il faut appliquer tout ça donc là on
réfléchit aux décrets d'application et
gosso lolo qui nous expose un petit peu
lui comment il va avancer
je regarde deux choses différentes il ya
les décrets d'urgence à prendre au
niveau des centres d'hébergement pour
changer complètement la politique
d'urgence qui est qui mise encore
aujourd'hui et puis et puis aller vers
la longue durée ça c'est accepter ça va
être décrétée très rapidement maintenant
je crois que oui sur le droit au
logement opposable il ya un rapport
qu'il faut étudier je pense qu'il est
plutôt bon de monsieur emmanuelli n'a
pas fait tout seul et voilà et ça ce
rapport là le droit au logement
opposable
il faut le patient projet de loi à
l'assemblée il faut l'unanimité autour
de ce projet évidemment malgré tout
d'étendre de sans abri sont toujours le
long du canal saint martin à paris
d'autres ont été installés dans d'autres
villes toulouse lille nice par exemple
quelle est l'utilité maintenant ces
nouveaux campements côté je crois que
nous tant que les choses ne sont pas
appliquées il faut continuer à camper
l'idée c'est que ces gens sortent de ces
campements avec la loi la loi qui va
être appliqué très vite a priori si à
urgence il faut agir urgemment pour
l'essentiel pour les sans abri en
l'occurrence et surtout pour eux et puis
les bien logés et les mal-logés je veux
dire en français évidemment vont pouvoir
bénéficier de sa voix du rejoint sur le
droit au logement opposable parme et
voilà je la loi va les sortir de là il
faut l'appliquer très vite et il faut
que ces gens partent grâce à l'état
lucio 630 en train de faire merci
beaucoup augustin legrand d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce soir en
direct